mehrere stunden dauert die schiffstour
von spitzbergens hauptort longyearbyen
zu den gletschern bei eisigem wind geht
es durch das kabel im nordpolarmeer
dann wird es plötzlich spannend ein
buckelwal begleitet das schiff ein paar
minuten bevor er wieder in die tiefen
der see abtaucht am nordens köln bremen
schlägt die stunde der cell wie
fotografen
das ewige eis der gletscher hier auf
spitzbergen fasziniert die touristen
viele nehmen die stunde lange anfahrt in
kauf um ihre bilder zu machen
aber die warmen temperaturen des sommers
die ungewöhnlich warme temperatur dieses
sommers setzen auch dem gletscher hier
oben stark zu im juli kletterten die
temperaturen auf rekordwerte von knapp
22 grad plus auch wenn es heute kaum
mehr als zwei sind sieht man dem
gletscher an dass der sommer viel zu
warm bahn
man kann deutlich sehen dass da immer
mehr eis abbricht
im letzten jahr waren die felsen hier
noch vom eis bedeckt jetzt schmilzt
immer mehr davon ab ganz einfach das ist
das ende der welt wenn du hier oben bist
kannst du das sehen
zu hause ist das alles nur theorie aber
hier kannst du das erleben professor
kehm hin ist leiter des norwegischen
polarinsel spitzbergen
er beobachtet seit jahrzehnten wie sich
die verhältnisse in der arktis verändern
der lebensraum der heimischen tiere
kleiner wird und das vermeintlich ewige
eis der gletscher binnen neunzig jahren
geschwunden ist die arktis als
zukunftslabor der menschheit
dass sich die arktis doppelt so schnell
erwärmt wie der rest des planeten rund
um spitzbergen steigen die arktischen
temperaturen am schnellsten
das ist eine vorwarnung auf das was auch
den rest der welt noch zu kommen am
himmel über spitzbergen ziehen seine
kollegen vom alfred-wegener-institut
ihre kreise
mit zwei polarforschung flugzeugen vom
typ dc-3 fliegen die wissenschaftler in
diesen wochen immer wieder von
spitzbergen aus über die arktis und
messen luftbewegungen und die dicke des
eises wir sehen einfach anhand der
messdaten dass das eis in der
franzstraße im gesamten märkischen ozean
immer dünner wird das liegt daran weil
es früher früher anfängt zu schmelzen
später anfangen zu führen das eis selber
driftet schneller als das treibt
schneller durch den arktischen ozean und
es ist dadurch insgesamt dünner
die forscher aus bremerhaven zeigen wir
ihre arbeitsplätze im innern der 75
jahre alten maschinen ihre messungen
haben gezeigt dass die eisdicke in der
polarregion in den letzten jahren um 25
prozent abgenommen hat
in weniger meereis in der arktis
vorfinde
umso stärker ist die energiequelle des
offenen ozeans für die arktis das führt
zu einer erwärmung der atmosphäre zur
veränderten luftmassen
transportprozessen das heißt das klima
wenn sich das klima verändert bedeutet
das automatisch dass sich das wetter in
der europa verändert sogar auf
spitzbergen hat der temperaturanstieg
den menschen in diesem sommer
ungewöhnliches t shirt wetter beschert
für die menschen die hier in arktis und
auf spitzbergen leben ist natürlich sind
temperaturen über 20 grad erst mal was
schönes auf der einen seite aber sie
führen dazu dass der permafrost auftaut
und damit natürlich die
lebensbedingungen eine ganz andere
werden
was passiert wenn die erde nicht mehr
frostig fest ist kann man gleich neben
der startbahn sehen
christiane hübner musste ihr haus
umsetzen als der boden bis in knapp zwei
metern tiefe auftauchte und die
stürmische see das weich gewordene ufer
mit sicheres von dem ersten fasten
unserer hütte bis hin zur kante war es
dann nur noch vier meter das heißt sehr
insgesamt hat es 13 meter weg gefüttert
nur in diesem einen ereignis wir haben
gehörte nach hinten umgezogen und hoffen
dass du da jetzt eine weile steht longa
wien nicht eingezwängt zwischen hügeln
die jetzt im frühherbst schon mal von
feinem schnee gepudert werden die
allgemeinen steigenden temperaturen auf
spitzbergen machen das leben hier aber
gefährlich selbst beim gedenken an die
toten
wie mir pastor in zivil im strand zeigt
durch viel regen und das auftauen des
permafrostboden sbe drohen erdrutsche
die friedhofs gänge was wir sehen ist
eine gerölllawine die vor vier jahren
direkt neben dem friedhof runter kam das
kann jederzeit wieder passieren und
deshalb planen wir einen neuen friedhof
bei der permafrostboden die särge nach
oben drückt werden nur noch urnen
bestattet aber auch das ist wegen der
lawinengefahr derzeit unmöglich
2016 gab es gar keine bestattungen mehr
das erinnert uns daran wo wir eigentlich
leben und was die arktis gerade
durchmacht und was die welt durch macht
[Musik]
hochzeit in der nördlichsten kirche der
welt pastorin sie bremst traut adelheid
und tom die vor jahren vom norwegischen
festland nach spitzbergen gekommen sind
jeder der hier arbeit findet darf sich
auf spitzbergen niederlassen viele
bleiben nur ein paar jahre spätestens
nach ende des berufslebens denen die
meisten zurück in ihre heimat
sie schließen einen bund fürs leben auch
wenn sich die lebensbedingungen immer
schneller verändern
[Musik]
wenn das hier im winter weiterhin so
viel regnet müssen wir ernsthaft
überlegen ob wir noch hier bleiben im
boden taut auf das eis schmilzt die
temperaturen steigen
das wird ganz bestimmt unser leben hier
auf spitzbergen verändern
es ist aber nicht nur der wandel des
klimas der ihnen in der arktis einiges
zumutet auf spitzbergen hängen sie am
tropf der reisebranche hat das gewehr
außerhalb libyens immer griffbereit als
schutz gegen begegnungen mit einem der
rund 3000 hier lebenden eisbären
er erzählt mir dass er seit 2005 zehn
touristen durch die arktische natur
führt aber seit ausbruch der korona
pandemie im frühjahr kommen kaum noch
urlauber das wird die tourismusbranche
hier oben ganz sicher treffen und
schlimme auswirkungen auf das leben hier
haben den spitzbergen hängt stark vom
geschäft mit dem norden
spitzbergen schlittenhunde ziehen jetzt
viel öfter kutschen mit fracht als
besucher aus der fremde und auch mischa
sitzt nur noch selten am steuer des
tourbusses willst du
ich habe mehr jobs gesucht während des
lockouts das wird mich natürlich auf die
dauer nicht ernähren aber irgendwer
braucht ja immer hilfe sei es beim
schneeräumen oder bei der reparatur des
autos
fischer will hierbleiben nicht wie viele
seiner freunde spitzbergen verlassen und
sich auf dem festland oder in seiner
heimat einen neuen job suchen mische
held aus fühle ich mich so sehr mit
diesem ort verbunden dass sich nicht
irgendwo anders leben möchte klar will
ich reisen an spitzbergen ist mein
zuhause aber sein zuhause ist
wirtschaftlich in not als im märz der
lockdown verhängt wurde
sollte die haupt zusammen gerade erst
beginnen so wurde die reisebranche in
diesem jahr ab gewirkt bevor sie richtig
in schwung kam erklärt mir ronny grund
voll vom lokalen tourismusverband besitz
vollbart
das ist ein 2 der hat doch die ist hilfe
aber sind nicht gewöhnt um hilfe zu
bitten ruft das ist hier eine raue
gegend oder eine raue gesellschaft und
wir haben das bislang immer selbst
geschaffen fühlen uns unabhängig aber
jetzt ist das anders
ich mache mir wirklich große sorgen um
die lokalen unternehmen vielen betrieben
droht das aus denn die pandemie bremst
den laufenden strukturwandel auf
spitzbergen weg vom bergbau hin zum
tourismus
industrie tourismus er soll jobs aus dem
bergbau ersetzen und das ist uns in den
letzten jahren auch ganz gut gelungen
trifft uns die krise doppelt der
tourismus wackelt und auch die letzte
kohle zeche hier hat ein problem
es war ein bergarbeiter die vor gut 100
jahren lumia wien aufgebaut haben um die
reichen kohle vorkommen auszubeuten
hoch oben über dem ort kann man die
ersten zeichen noch erkennen
sie sind genauso stumme zeugen der
längst vergangenen blütezeit des
steinkohlebergbaus auf spitzbergen wie
die alte russische zechensiedlung
pyramiden die moskau 1998 binnen weniger
monate stillgelegt hat noch immer weht
ein postsozialistische auch durch den
verlassenen ort heute erscheint das
grotesk dass sich ausgerechnet in der
arktis kohlehalden auftürmen
die das kraftwerk von longyearbyen mit
brennstoffversorgung es ist halt einfach
historisch bedingt dass hier kohle
abgebaut wird und ich meine dass der
abdruck der ob die coole hier abgebaut
wird oder woanders ist im grunde wurscht
weil es co2 verteilte je schneller eine
atmosphäre die kohle ist eins der
wenigen sachen die nicht importiert wird
hier der rest wird mit auch sehr hohem
co2 abdruck hierher gebracht weil die
menschen hier weltweit den größten pro
kopf ausstoß an co2 haben suchen sie auf
spitzbergen trotzdem nach
umweltfreundlicheren alternativen zum
verbrennen von kohle müssen eine lösung
finden die besser mit der arktischen
natur harmoniert das können wind oder
wellenkraftwerke seien auf jeden fall
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass die natur
nicht weiter blutet
gefördert nur der juli bleibt tief drin
im dauerfrost der alten kohle zeigt mir
aber 14 uhr wo sie schon vor über 30
jahren begonnen haben die alten stollen
sinnvoll weiter zu nutzen
hinter dieser tür haben sie norwegen
saatgut bank untergebracht und das
wertvolle genmaterial vor katastrophen
und kriegen zu schützen
in zwischenlagern hier die samen von
über einer million pflanzenarten aus der
ganzen welt und stetig bringt osmo
dostal neue lieferungen in den
erweiterten saatgut bunker hier sichern
sie die künftige versorgung der
menschheit mit nahrungsmitteln um das
saatgut vor eindringendem schmelzwasser
in folge des klimawandels zu schützen
musste norwegen kürzlich umgerechnet 20
millionen euro investieren
neuer hatte keine klasse das saatgut der
ganzen welt anvertraut ganz gleich ob
nord oder süd arm oder reich die staaten
verlassen sich darauf dass wir uns
kümmern und gut auf die samen acht geben
damit sie immer verfügbar sind wenn sie
gebraucht werden
einmal bereits muster ein land auch
seine hier gelagerten samen
zurückgreifen
syrien saatgut bank ging in den wirren
des dortigen bürgerkriegs verloren
möglicherweise hatten die syrer kopien
ihrer samen hier eingelagert und als sie
die brauchten waren sie hier in
sicherheit mit den samen aus der arktis
konnten die syrer neue saatgut banken
aufbauen
die nachzüchtungen lagern bereits wieder
tief unter tage im bunker auf
spitzbergen
es bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit das
auftauen der arktis zu stoppen und die
menschheit ihr saatgut für künftige
generationen aufbewahrt